he's run our tests he's also Metta World
Peace Metta World Peace joining us on
behalf of expert SAP lat form bringing
together sports professionals players
and enthusiasts and facilities the
building of offline and online sports
communities also Mehta has a book no
malice my life in basketball available
online and wherever books are sold Metta
World Peace who was I believe drafted by
the Bulls the year after Michael Jordan
retired Metta how are you today
much appreciated today now what was it
like that you go to the Bulls right
after Jordan decides that he's going to
retire what was that feeling like that
you come to town and then Mike's not
even going to be there you know people
of cobia people you know and you don't
really get it until you take a step back
and you watch the last wow I really love
you know the Bulls and I felt I'm it's
been drafted and then you played against
he went to the Wizards I don't know how
many times you played against him but I
think he probably had close to 30 on you
guys when you played against him how
many times did you face Jordan right
when he came back he was averaging 25
that year so I faced a really good older
and then I faced the decline in the
older Michael Jordan I think the next
year his productivity went down but the
first day he came back he was playing
amazing what was it like to guard him it
was amazing because he was still able to
score he averaged 25 points you know the
first Shea came back and I mean anybody
has ever done 25 points is going to be a
problem
it wasn't easy he could score a ball did
he talk you know I mean Jordan talked
and I never got any trash talk
joining the only the closest things
Jordans ever said to me was when I was
19 years old that we were playing
basketball he was saying uh hey come
back and play it you know in the summer
times oh well
and because he competed against him so
hard and that was a honnor you know it's
a continue to get back invited he really
wanted me to garden how did you break
his ribs it was accident you know so he
was me you let Jody with the ball he's
going to score and only way he can keep
him from spoons if you don't let him get
the ball so I was denying him and I went
in my left hand went over his left
shoulder was left on my right arm was
positioned to move him up the way in a
game position his left arm had me and
locked
I remember to play clear his day kids
he's like my favorite players and then
the referee called the offensive foul
when Jody because he was holding and I
was just trying to fight to get him
friends it was summertime I was open run
over referees and it was great but you
know unfortunately you know broke his
ribs and I felt like he gonna have a 35
when he came back after three months of
just taking a break he averaged 29 he's
just really amazed how many would he
average in today's given today's rules
where there's no hand check in here
everything's spread spread open here
Mehta what's Jordan average peak Jordan
1991-92 what's Jordan average today you
know I think would be about the same
maybe Ricky
nobody's narrative twenty-eight hazard
right so he would he would he would
probably have done the same thing but I
think everything is spread open
you know everybody's on the perimeter
and Mike loved that 15 18 foot jumper
and he could take you to the hoop I he's
averaging 40 a game meta I just touching
absolutely because he's so fundamentally
sound he's always on balance so it's
really tough when I can't see him no
James Hardie with 1:38 right now yeah
but Mike would be better than James
Harden yeah Mike average that one didn't
he averaged thirty seven point one one
year he's gonna average four there's
nobody at the rim to stop him who were
the great rim protectors the Lopez
brothers it is true because while the
rim protection is coming back it was you
all know American bigs was not producing
over the last like thirty five years but
now I think joining just hard to say I
can't really see it but yeah somewhere
around 35 to 40 what's the difference
regarding Jordan and guarding Kobe very
similar Jordan's just I would say Kobe's
more of a modern-day Jordan right and a
Jordan is probably a a more polished dr.
J you know and it's a very very similar
Jordan is more on balance you know Kobe
was but they both were very effective as
we know they played the same exact way
he's Metta World Peace joining us on the
program tell me if you approach Kobe
about winning a title together but you
weren't on the Lakers when you approach
Kobe about winning a title was divide
that story right this noise correct
well it wasn't did approach him so after
they lost 2008 to the Boston Celtics
I went to that game because I wanted to
get some experience on how it is to be a
and a championship building so a game
they lose by 30 I'm like oh wow this is
an amazing atmosphere this is what I'm
really instead and when I get to the
championship games so can I go back to
say bottom Lamar and then I see Phil
Jackson and I say hey yeah it's called
me I want to say good game if I'm a big
fan I also haven't if you code me that
year also
well I did interview up with comeon so
I'm a fan and he was in a shower I
wanted to leave and then Brian trusted
he's in the back and I just say tapped
him on the shoulder he was just like
kind of mad at me just lost
he was real surprised to see me in the
shower and not to say I gotta go but I
wanted to save her game so I got out cuz
I'm really you know I'm really no
problem you did a good job you know and
that was it it wasn't really I was with
the Kings at that time how long did you
wear your Jersey after the Lakers won
the title
full full uniform how long did you keep
it on to the studio dr. Dre recorded me
it was crazy
wait wait you're with dr. Dre you just
all over the place in LA studio and my
record champions came out so that that
drink actually produced Champions part
two I love that but and then you were 37
for a little while yeah yeah but was
that actually and I once again you
probably have told these stories so many
times I just like to get fact and
fiction here that Michael Jackson's
Thriller was number one on Billboard
charts for 37 straight weeks and that's
how you chose 37 trying to put numbers
to greatness and I'm like wow that's
pretty great 37 weeks that's huge and
okay and why why were you
drinking Hennessy at halftime of a game
if that's true when you worth the Bulls
is that true that you drank Hennessy I'd
have to well first of all Hennessy come
on a little bit but I love your honesty
you know every time I talk to you I just
like you know that the fact that you
sold your championship ring and you
donated the proceeds from that I mean
they're just there's a lot of greatness
in your heart there and and I and I hope
you're at a good spot in your life and
what you're doing with X versus X sports
you know like I hope things are good for
you
back then you know athlete is always
trying to figure out what they're gonna
do and the same in the future so right
now just a Coronet we at least could be
so a support system for any athletes
that potentially can be you don't feel
the same way and now I think they know
they have huge sources but you were one
of the first that did this though Metta
you came out and you talked about mental
health you know we've seen some of these
athletes Michael Phelps Kevin Love you
you came out and started talking about
this and you know people can look at you
two different ways like that guy's crazy
or that guy you know the first sign of
being needing help or asking for help is
being honest with people and and I
viewed it as you're just saying look I
need help I'm figuring this out myself
don't look at me as well that's the
crazy guy who started the malice and the
Palance there I mean there was honesty
there and you put yourself out there
absolutely try to put on an image if
you're an athlete you're trying to get
endorsements you know you're gonna put
on the image accordingly right and the
image is not always reality right so
sometimes you have to show the road we
have the reality in the road
and some people need something to relate
to you know because music only
commercials that's just not all real
[Music]
it's a little different than how you
grew up in New York right the the book
is no malice it's my life in basketball
x vs x sports it's a platform bringing
together sports professionals players
enthusiasts and online offline sports
community you've got a basketball hoop
at the house I had curry did the same
thing Steph Curry moved into a house it
didn't have a hoop Metta you know what
I'm thinking he's so good as a shooter
he doesn't need to practice you gotta
pay people to put that stuff together
for you great to talk to you
always great we appreciate your time and
in good luck with X versus X and of
course the book that's available
wherever books are sold
all right that's a Metta World Peace
always one of our favorites